My name's Chris Bavitz, I'm a clinical
professor of law at Harvard Law School.
I'm one of the faculty co-directors at
the Berkman Klein Center for Internet
and Society. We're really focused on
specific situations where the government
is using algorithmic tools. Are we doing
so thoughtfully? Are we understanding the
ramifications? Are we satisfied with the
level of transparency or the level of
interpretability of a particular outcome from one of
these tools? The most obvious place where this is happening is in the
criminal justice system with respect to
tools that help support decisions around
things like sentencing, bail, and parole.
These are decisions that have
traditionally been left to judges to
make, weighing factors related to the
defendant that's before them. In the
context of a decision about bail for
example, whether the defendant is likely to flee the
jurisdiction if we let him or her go
after arrest and before their trial. How
dangerous they are, whether they're
likely to cause harm to the community if
we release them. Some of those decisions now are being, I don't want to say
they're being "handed over" to these
technical tools, but they're being
facilitated by risk scores that are
being given to defendants.
And I think that there is enormous
potential in the use of these kinds of
tools to help eliminate some of the
biases that creep in when we have human
decision-makers who themselves are
biased, or making decisions about
defendants in the criminal justice
system. I also think that if designed
poorly or designed without adequate
consideration to context there's a risk
that we might actually entrench existing
biases and in fact make it harder to get
at those biases, make these decisions
less transparent, less understandable,
both to the defendants and to society as
a whole. We're starting out by just
trying to gather as much information as
we can about these tools in the way
they're being used out there in the
world. We're also doing a bunch of legal
research and policy analysis kinds of
projects that relate to figuring out
good ways, reasonable ways, to regulate
the use of these tools so we're trying
to think about whether there are
existing regulatory models out there
that might be helpful when the question
comes up "how can we regulate government
use of these algorithms?" Do we want them to be subject to some sort of government
oversight? Do we want to be providing the
government actors and procure these
tools with some sets of best practices
or standards that they should be
following when they're facing an
invitation from a vendor to purchase one
of these tools? What kinds of questions
should they be asking? And we're also
trying to do some work on the deployment side. So we talked about sort of the
development, the procurement of the tools by the
government officers who use them, and
then the way that they're deployed in
courts, typically a judge who actually
has in front of of him or her a risk
score that he or she can consider in
making a particular decision, we're
trying to examine the ways in which judges are
using these scores and make sure that
they're being used fairly, reasonably. That the parties that actually make use of them understand what they mean.
That, for example, a factor that went into the assessment of a risk score does not then
get double counted by the judge who goes ahead and considers that same factor
again as part of the analysis. That the
judge understands that the risk score is
accomplishing these certain goals and
that the judge is then supposed to
exercise his or her judgment with
respect to a set of other goals and kind
of trying to map the system so that we
make sure judges are understanding where
these are being used. By using the use of
these tools in the criminal justice
system as our case study we could get
at a bunch of other questions about
places where government might use these tools in general when it comes again to
allocating resources, deploying law
enforcement personnel or health
inspectors, helping to draw voting
districts, those kinds of things. So I
think we're using the criminal justice piece again as a bit of
a case study to try and get at these
broader questions, all of which have in
common the fact that it's a government
that's making use of these tools.